Welcome to the Deep dive, where
we take a stack of sources and
really try to pull out the most
important Nuggets of knowledge
for you.
That's right.
Today we're embarking on a
really fascinating deep dive.
We've got writings here that
explore the, let's say, nuanced
dance between identity,
visibility, and protection.
Yeah, we're looking at some
pretty deep concepts.
Things like the vampire door,
this idea that stealth is not
shame, and a really striking
analysis of why sanctions are
war when it comes to identity.
It's really all about
understanding how your sense of
self, you know, your identity
can be this incredibly powerful
force, but also sometimes how it
can make you vulnerable, a
target even in a world that's,
well, always shifting.
Right.
So our mission today is to
unpack these ideas.
We want to share some of the
historical context from the
sources and also look at recent
legal developments that show how
visibility can be powered.
That there's a catch exactly,
but only if you understand how,
as the sources put it, the pack
moves.
So get ready for some, I think,
surprising facts and moments
that might just make you see
your own identity and the spaces
you use in a totally new light.
Should be interesting.
OK, so let's jump right into
this this foundational idea, the
vampire door.
Can you maybe paint a clear
picture?
What exactly are the sources
describing here?
Sure.
The author describes it as a
kind of portal, almost a
threshold you cross where you
can be fully seen, like, truly
yourself for maybe a few hours.
OK.
And then just as easily, you
become invisible again.
You slip back into your, you
know, everyday life.
It's this door that swings both
ways.
It offers sanctuary.
Yeah, but also potentially it
could be a trap if you're not
careful.
And the author's own experience
with this, it started in
Norwich, England, way back in
1990.
I love this image.
They paint farmers, you know,
still in their muddy wellies
during the day, but then at
night they slip into a gay
disco, glitter on their collars,
the whole thing.
And then, crucially, they cloak
up and they're gone before dawn.
That really captures it, doesn't
it?
That fleeting nature.
It really does the essence of
it.
And what's interesting is the
author apparently saw something
similar even earlier in DC 1988
around Dupont Circle, described
as a neon fever dream.
You know, drag races, block
parties, fetish shops, just this
really vibrant scene.
Sounds intense.
It was a bigger, maybe sweaty or
vampire door and the quote here
is great.
The bar at 7 is a family
reunion, but the bar at 11 is
the pack.
Wow, OK, that distinction is
key. 7 versus 11?
Definitely.
So the lesson or the the take
away for the author seems pretty
clear.
Step through when you need to
slip out before the wolves get
curious.
This idea of managing your
visibility, being strategic
about it, that feels really
central to everything else.
Absolutely.
And it builds, you know,
building on that vampire door
logic.
The author found something
similar happening in the early
Internet.
Oh.
Interesting.
How so?
And what we're called walled
gardens, places like the Met
network, the well, these weren't
just open forums anyone could
wander into.
Right.
Not like today's social media.
Not at all.
You needed a password, maybe an
invitation.
Sometimes you even needed
someone already inside to vouch
for you.
So it sounds almost like a like
a digital lodge or maybe a fire
circle.
The author compares it to their
Freemason lodge experience.
Exactly, that's the analogy
used.
The building itself might be
public visible, but when those
doors close there's a guard.
Literally a man with a sword in
the lodge example and he's not
there to hoard treasure.
OK, so why is he there?
Because, and this is a direct
quote, context is fragile.
Context is fragile, so it's not
just about secrecy, but
protecting the meaning of what
happens inside the
vulnerability.
You got it.
That's the core idea that
meaning leaks when the wrong
eyes peak.
Meaning leaks.
Yeah.
And to leak the lodge or, you
know, expose the inner workings
of that safe space is basically
to salt the garden.
Salt the garden, destroy the
environment.
Exactly.
You destroy the very thing that
allows for that true connection,
that space where you can be
fully seen without being, you
know, misinterpreted or
exploited.
OK, this next point from the
sources, it really challenges a
common idea.
It's quite provocative.
Stealth is not shame.
Yeah, that one makes you stop
and think.
What's the strategy behind that
statement?
What are they getting at?
Well, I think for a lot of
people, when they hear stealth,
the first thing that comes to
mind is fear, right?
Or hiding something because
you're ashamed.
Sure, that makes sense.
But the author really emphasizes
that in this context, it's a
deliberate strategy.
It's about self preservation.
They use an analogy like a
concealed carry instructor
saying the best weapon is the
one nobody knows you have.
OK.
So it's tactical.
Exactly.
It's about keeping your cloak
close, because for many folks,
the street outside is still
1950.
Things haven't changed as much
as we might think.
So the goal then, of this kind
of stealth is often just
survival, to stay alive long
enough to shout again tomorrow.
That's a big part of it, yeah.
But then there's this other
concept introduced is the YWP.
The YWP like Walt Whitman.
Precisely Walt Whitman's term
for that raw, defiant expression
of self.
Whitman sources call him
America's Big Queer Bard,
writing about hips and lips and
alleys.
Very embodied stuff.
Very embodied, very
unapologetic.
But here's the tension the
author points out.
America seems to love the idea
of the YWP, but maybe only when
it's safe, when it's embalmed.
Embalmed.
How so?
Think, oh, captain, my captain,
the Whitman poem everyone reads
in school.
It's acceptable, right?
Memorialized.
Yeah, required reading.
But the living, raw, messy,
uncontainable yiwp, the sources
argue America often hates that,
resists it fiercely.
That comparison to uranium is
really striking.
Then it captures that danger
doesn't.
It it really does.
When you get too loud, too
visible, you can become uranium.
You're radiant, potent, yes, but
you're also.
You're also the perfect fuel to
refine, spin up and point back
at you when the machine decides
it's time to push you back
under.
Wow, so it's that duality.
You're power, your visibility,
can be turned into a weapon
against you by external forces.
Precisely.
The power itself isn't
inherently the problem, just
like uranium isn't dangerous
sitting there.
It's how it's processed,
refined, and directed.
Your yawp, your visible
identity, becomes a target for
those who want to control the
narrative, exploit it, or just
shut it down when this system,
the machine, feels threatened.
It's a stark warning about
visibility without maybe
strategic awareness turning your
strength into a liability.
Exactly.
And this leads into how these
control tactics have evolved,
according to the sources.
We move from just thinking about
physical spaces or social
pressure to something maybe more
insidious in the modern world.
Financial leverage.
Yeah, economic.
Pressure, right?
And this is where that concept,
sanctions or war comes into
play.
But applied internally, the
sources point to the Supreme
Court.
Scrametty ruling in 2025 is a
key example.
This upheld Tennessee's ban on
gender firming care for minors.
Yeah, a major case.
How does that ruling based on
our sources actually function
like sanction?
How does it turn off the faucet
for care?
Well, the ruling itself, it was
a six, three decision and it
leaned heavily on the idea of
states having a compelling
interest in protecting minors.
It gave states really broad
leeway if they just claim health
and safety concerns.
Now, importantly, it didn't
technically outlaw being a trans
kid.
Right, not an outright ban on
identity.
But it's starved.
The care starved the identity,
as the source puts it, by
banning access to puberty
blockers, hormone therapy for
minors within that state.
And while it didn't directly
banned adult care in that
specific ruling, the source is
really stressed.
The potential chilling effect.
Restrictions from insurance
companies.
Clinics becoming wary.
And the scale.
The sources note that over half
of U.S. states had similar bills
proposed or enacted around that
time, so it wasn't an isolated
thing.
And there's another example from
2025 cited the Supreme Court
decision allowing states to
block Planned Parenthood from
all Medicaid funding.
Yeah, that was another big one.
And this wasn't just about
abortion, right?
Because public funds generally
couldn't be used for that
anyway.
Exactly this.
Hit contraception, cancer
screenings, routine check UPS,
basic healthcare for millions
who rely on Medicaid and use
Planned Parenthood as their
provider.
So what was the mechanism there?
How did the court justify that?
The key finding, according to
the sources, was that individual
Medicaid patients cannot sue
states for cutting off specific
providers like Planned
Parenthood.
OK, so it removed the patient's
recourse?
Pretty much.
It gave states the power to
defund based on vaguely defined
reasons like the provider
supposed moral character, which
the sources argue makes the
whole idea of Medicaid offering
freedom of choice for patients
much more theoretical than real.
It's a way to choke off services
financially.
And the author draws this Direct
Line.
This is the same tactic, the
same kind of economic squeeze
used against countries like
Cuba, Iran or Russia.
But.
Turned inward against its own
citizens, Yeah.
The system the pack demands you
amputate.
The peace that makes a squirm?
Cut off the part of yourself or
your community that's deemed
unacceptable.
And if you won't or can't?
The pack says fine, starve.
It's stark.
It's using economic weapons
essentially pointed right at
identity.
Which brings us right back to
that image, doesn't it?
The Wolves at 11.
Right.
Remind us.
The bar at 7:00?
That's your found family, your
safe space, your sanctuary.
OK, but the bar at 11, when
things get real, when the
outside world's pressure start
to seep in or show their teeth,
that's the werewolves.
And this pack of wolves, it's
bigger than just, you know,
people in a bar.
Oh, much bigger.
The sources define it broadly.
It includes the lawyer with a
ballot.
Influencing laws.
The think tank with a donor
list.
Shaping policy and opinion.
And maybe most chillingly, the
1950 ghosts still living inside
the court, the City Hall, Your
neighbors vote these embedded
older attitudes.
It's a pervasive force, then,
often subtle.
Very and really critical point
the author makes is you just
can't extrapolate from the
sweaty pride parade to the rest
of the country.
Meaning the vibe at a specific
celebratory event isn't the
whole picture.
Not even close.
The pack, those opposing forces,
they're always circling your
YIWP, your authentic self that's
real, is powerful.
But so are the antibodies it
summons.
Antibodies it summons.
I like that phrasing.
So this vibe shift we hear
about, it's not just a general
mood change, it's more like a
societal immune response
specifically triggered by that
YIWP becoming more visible.
That's exactly how the sources
frame it.
It's a reaction, sometimes a
backlash, specifically to that
visibility.
It makes it very clear how just
being seen can provoke
resistance.
OK, so it's not a gentle shift,
it's a reaction.
So given all this, these forces,
these wolves, how do you
navigate it?
Well, the sources try to offer
some practical guidance.
There's a Vampire Door field
guide section and also Ten ways
to Stay submarine.
A field guide.
OK, what kind of places count as
vampire doors today?
All sorts, really.
The obvious ones like queer bars
yes, but also house parties,
bath houses, ballrooms and
online.
Think of those walled gardens
again.
Maybe password protected forms
or discord servers where you
need manual vetting to get in
right?
Controlled digital spaces.
Yeah, and they can even be solo
spaces, your late night walk, a
handwritten diary kept private,
anywhere you can be fully you
without immediate scrutiny.
And the key insight here?
The small truth the author
mentions.
Is that a vampire door?
Only works if it stays partly
hidden.
Partly hidden.
Yeah, once you broadcast it, you
invite the pack in and the
author is clear this isn't about
being exclusionary just for the
sake of it.
It's not gatekeeping.
It's garden keeping.
That's the phrase used.
Can you elaborate on that?
Why garden keeping?
Think about a real garden.
You tend it, you protect it from
pests or harsh weather, right?
Not to keep people out
maliciously, but to allow
specific, maybe delicate things
to grow.
There things that couldn't
survive out in the open field.
Exactly.
So garden keeping is about
nurturing and protecting that
specific environment, that
context, broadcasting the
location.
Leaking the lodge is like
salting your own garden.
It kills the very conditions
needed for vulnerability and
true expression.
That makes sense.
Protecting the soil,
essentially, you got it.
And building on that, those ten
ways to stay submarine, they
sound like practical tactics.
What are some?
Of them, yeah, they're pretty
concrete things like keep your
close circle small and trusted.
Separate your public face from
your private garden.
Using an alias, for instance,
can be like armor.
Pay attention.
Watch for that vibe shift we
talked about.
Don't dox the door.
Meaning don't publicly reveal
safe spaces.
Right.
Protect the garden.
Keep records, encrypt your
communications where needed.
Practice blending in sometimes.
The sources mentioned the Gray
Man mindset.
Man, just blending into the
background.
Basically, yeah, not drawing
unnecessary attention when you
don't need to.
Also practicing strategic
silence, staying connected with
your trusted people, and
crucially, always remembering
that point.
Stealth is strategy, not shame.
It's a whole toolkit for
navigating potentially hostile
environments.
That's the idea.
Now, looking at these recent
legal shifts, these strategies,
it feels important to remember
this didn't just happen
overnight.
The sources provide a timeline.
Yeah, the historical context is
really eliminating.
You can trace this thread way
back.
I mean the first known US gay
rights group, the Society for
Human Rights.
He was founded and then shut
down by authorities way back in
1924.
Wow, 1924.
Then you had groups like the
Manicheen Society in the 1950s
operating using these small
secret cells, essentially
vampire doors, right?
And the Daughters of Belitus,
another early group, starting
with private house parties for
lesbians, again creating safe
hidden spaces then.
Stonewall in 1969.
The sources call that a moment
where the vampire door became a
battleground.
A flashpoint, exactly.
A moment of defiant visibility,
but also intense conflict.
Later on, you see moments of
progress, like the American
Psychiatric Association removing
homosexuality from the DSM ton
in 1973.
That was huge.
My mental and then the HIV AIDS
epidemic in the 80s and 90's.
The sources point to the AIDS
Memorial Quilt as serving as a
kind of vampire door itself.
How so?
A quilt.
As a public record, yes, but
also a shield, a way for a
grieving, besieged community to
make its presence felt, to
remember and define solidarity,
often in the face of public
indifference or hostility.
It was both visible and
protective.
That's a powerful image.
And then more recent legal
battles.
Progress often seemed hard won,
didn't it?
Very Obergefell V Hodges in
2015, establishing same sex
marriage rights nationwide.
That was a nail biting 54
Supreme Court decision.
So close.
And Bostocky, Clayton County in
2020, extending Title 7
workplace protections to LGBTQ
workers.
That was 63 important victories,
but often resting on narrow
margins.
Which makes the context for the
2025 rulings we discussed
Scrumetti, the Planned
Parenthood funding case, even
clearer.
They represent a shift back
towards restriction using these
financial sanctions.
Exactly.
It shows how fragile progress
can be and how tactics evolve.
OK, As we talk about these
complex legal rulings, there are
a couple of key distinctions the
sources emphasize things that
often get confused in public
discussion.
Yeah, it's.
Important to be precise here.
Can you clarify what these
rulings actually did according
to the sources, and maybe just
as importantly, what they didn't
do?
Absolutely.
So it is true that the Scriminy
ruling essentially gave a green
light to state level bans on
gender affirming care for
minors.
That's accurate.
And it's true that the Planned
Parenthood decision made it
much, much harder for patients
to sue states if they get cut
off from their chosen Medicaid
provider.
It's also true that both these
rulings operate by using
funding, or the denial of
funding as leverage.
Like sanctions used
internationally but turned
inward, that comparison holds.
OK, so those are the truth.
What about the falsehoods or
misconceptions?
Well, it's false, according to
the sources, that these bans
directly make being trans
illegal.
They don't outlaw the identity
itself, but they.
Make life very difficult.
Extremely difficult.
They starve the care.
As we said, they scare clinics
and providers.
They create immense barriers.
But it's not technically illegal
to be trans.
That's an important distinction
in how the mechanism works, and
it's also crucially false, the
sources warned.
To think this won't spread the
playbook.
Using financial levers, citing
moral character or health and
safety, can absolutely be
copied.
And it already is being copied
by states targeting different
groups or services based on
their own particular moral
lines.
So the impact is potentially
much broader.
That's a really vital
clarification.
Thanks.
Wow.
This has been an incredibly
insightful deep dive.
We've covered so much ground on
identity, visibility,
protection, exploring how our
sense of self exists on this
whole spectrum, from the
strategic safety of the vampire
door all the way to that raw,
defiant power of the YWP.
And then looking at how these
modern strategies, these
sanctions are being used to push
back against that visibility.
And hopefully you've seen that
understanding things like the
vibe shift or the Wolves at 11,
it's not really about trying to
make people afraid.
No, it's about awareness.
It's about strategic awareness,
That key phrase.
Again, stealth is not shame.
It's strategy.
And remembering that context is
like a garden.
You have to guard it.
That final message from the
author really pulls it all
together, doesn't it?
That dance between power and
vulnerability?
It does.
Be careful what you ask for.
Visibility is power, but only if
you understand how the pack
moves.
Your yawp is holy.
So is your cloak.
Yeah.
What stands out to me there is
how it forces you to rethink
visibility itself.
It's not automatically good or
bad, is it?
It's effect really depends on
who's looking and why and how.
That's a crucial take away.
Visibility needs strategy, and
if you remember nothing else
from our dive today, maybe
remember this quote.
The vibe shift is real.
It always has been.
Every vampire door in history
has been raided, infiltrated, or
exploited when the coordinates
leaked.
Sobering reminder.
But did the hope?
But new ones always grow because
the YWP can't be killed, only
cloaked.
Keep it alive, Guard your
garden.
Leave before 11.
Leave before 11, before the
wolves get curious.
Exactly.
It highlights the resilience,
the adaptability of identity and
community.
New sanctuaries emerge even as
the landscape changes.
So thinking about all this, what
stands out to you listening
right now?
How does this idea of guarding
your garden, managing your
visibility apply to your own
life, your own communities, the
spaces you inhabit online or
off?
It's definitely a profound
thought to carry forward as you
navigate your own journey
through this complex world.